[Music]
hi my name is zachary porter and you
might recognize me now from my tick tock
yes you got out of work early
or any silly little internet video that
has me screaming on camera that sounds
weird and you may remember me or you
probably definitely don't remember me
from the teen safety video for rhode
island um in 2017.
sometimes it's obvious which jobs aren't
safe for teens in rhode island there's
some jobs you shouldn't be hired to do
so i went to school in rhode island
college for advertising and public
relations and one of the stipulations
for being in my ad program is that we
had to help this ad agency and they made
me do this teen safety commercial where
i had to talk to teens about if they
don't feel safe in their work
environment there's a number you can
call and you can report it to make sure
that you have safe working conditions
you don't have to do those jobs and you
don't have to worry about getting in
trouble if you don't at the time i was
already 22 years old i was a full-grown
man living on my own but they had to
literally kind of make me look very
youthful and kind of play up like i'm
nervous about this job so i really
should call this number when you have a
question about what jobs are tasks or
safe for teens just call
and i don't think anyone
probably 25 people saw that commercial
but i thought it was pretty cool because
it was a full set i loved it